esta situación nos pone en un problema
cambiario básicamente cuya variable de
ajuste es la importación se podría
compensar con más exportaciones se
podría compensar con otro tipo de
medidas pero evidentemente no las
tenemos hoy vigentes y eso hace que
nuestras reservas en el banco central
vayan disminuyendo drásticamente
[Música]
argentina tiene un vínculo muy estrecho
con lo que es café en un montón de
sentidos siempre nosotros decimos que el
café es la excusa ya sea tanto por
sentarse en un café de especialidad
chiquito como te vas al café de la
esquina oa un bar notable y a veces no
solo tomas café sino una excusa como
para encontrarte con tu amigo
[Música]
y honestamente creo que no vamos a
llegar al desabastecimiento pero si por
ello va haber un mayor cuidado de
materia prima para poder abastecer a
todos los negocios y que nadie se quede
difícil con eso
[Música]
no es solamente la importación de
productos terminados sino también el
factor crítico que representa no poder
abastecerse con la previsibilidad
necesaria de insumos y materias primas
que necesitábamos bienes de capital
repuestos partes y piezas para poder
mantener la maquinaria productiva
funcionando y de forma competitiva
[Música]